I was online yesterday and said that if  your spouse dies it feels like losing  three hundred and eight thousand seven  hundred dollars a year we put its dollar  amount on death how's that even a thing  with the price tag  not was the glue that helps together  I hate how in the beginning everyone  wants to send you flowers and stop  calling and writing doing nice things  for you because they're over us and they  expect you'd be over think you mean but  you really didn't know him as well as  you go do you know your husband's  passcode to his phone doesn't everyone  in otherwise they'd wonder who is  texting that he didn't want me to see my  sisters in free fall I just want to know  things about him that I didn't get to  know  [Music]  nothing they feed people right now but  think about a year from two years from  now that was my favorite person and now  I just mad all the time  you have to show off for yourself  whatever you need to feel you get to  feel it  [Music]  you  you